in East London a textile factory that
reflects the nation's cultural patchwork
workers here come from families that
move to the UK over the course of
decades from countries beyond the EU
immigration has shaped Britain but what
happens after brexit but today we
started getting some answers assigned at
Britain's future lies in welcoming some
migrants but not always meet Jason
Bourne in Greece now a nurse working in
Watford Jason came to the UK in 2016
he's a skilled worker and those are the
people who are likely to be prioritized
it's a relief to know that someone
values us and think that we are valued
in this country it's not that we came
here to take someone else's job it's
that we were needed
Jason's journey to the UK was easy
powered by freedom of movement within
the European Union but with brexit that
will change and according to the
independent migration Advisory Committee
new priorities will now be needed the
report's key recommendation calls on
ministers to lift the cap on
high-skilled workers people such as
teachers doctors or engineers while at
the same time limiting the number of
low-skilled workers like waiters
cleaners and construction workers who
are allowed into Britain after brexit it
also says there should not be
preferential treatment for EU citizens
compared to those from elsewhere in the
world and that's a policy supported by
majority of the public according to Sky
data we think that the the impacts of
migration depend on things like the
skills the migrant has but not
fundamentally on their nationality so if
you want to accentuate the benefits from
migration you should focus on on what is
important which is not nationality the
government commissioned this report and
says it will now carefully consider the
findings or fewer dispute that a big
global economy like Britain's should
strive to attract highly skilled workers
from around the world so a bigger
question may be this
if we curtail the number of lower
skilled workers coming into the country
will there be enough Brits to fill the
gaps back in the factory
the owner has loyal long-serving staff
and worries how he'll ever replace them
okay young generation they are not
interested on low-skilled what there is
huge opportunity opportunity for our
next generation who studying here school
University they can be high scale but we
are sort of low skilled worker migration
will change out to protect and that will
reshape the structure of Britain's
economy and its society these are big
fundamental questions
Adam Parsons Sky News